what's up reject nation we are going to
watch today the next episode of kingdom
guys you know the drill hit that like
button if you're going to join our
reaction do we need to say anything
subscribe patreon
you've been here
thanks to prepper for cutting down the
highlights whoo
yep you know or anybody really
[Music]
[Music]
they should they want to draw a fire
yeah
got to be people still looking for them
there's also the zombies
that's true
yeah sure just send her off by herself
torching everything what's the worst
that gets the worst could happen foggy
ass woods
let's get an evil dead tracking shot in
here hold on
sorry
foreign
who could have seen this coming
not i
this would seem like a fake out maybe
it's a guy disguised as a zombie
he had his reservations
[Music]
the pig lives that pig will be a damn
hero by the end of this
oh he's familiar with such a curse
[Music]
this guy does not seem phased by any of
it
damn these zombies are so good
oh the pig thing yeah
man made it all that way
and that pig survived all that [ __ ]
killed zombie carnage just to be lunch
yeah
what's
foreign
it could be daylight for long
yes it's a good thing i got a lot of
people to fight with him yep
kill it
don't just stand there for god's sakes
prince cut its head off
hey eerie
[Laughter]
oh my god
oh my god
[Applause]
yeah is your orders
oh they just keep coming
no
he must live he's the best one yes
you can grapple got close range you got
guns what can he do
no no no
do not touch him
no no no no no no no no no no
don't get anywhere else
oh my god
i know
nice
get up man
team needs you
what what
is it the is it the guy
[Music]
zombie kill of the week
just the man i've been looking for
don't get lost in each other's gates for
too long oh okay they're fine stare all
you want that was an intense
oh did he like trade him and take care
of him separate yeah i guess so
foreign
the whole reason he's the way he is is
because of him yeah
wow
are we sure all the zombies are gone
before we start dealing we're taking
inventory of all the ship corpses guys
are also caught in a fire right now
that's gonna spread us
he acknowledges it wow
and so it begins
how's your wife doing
let's get a massage a facial and what
i'm looking to spry tomorrow
they testing out the infection i think
the disease yeah
oh you sick bastards god ugh
[Music]
[Music]
is finally coming around a little bit
step one
[Laughter]
a little late there buddy
there's your containment plan
can you fix my penis first
are they are they eating regular food i
just don't think so
there's no reason they would be this
kind
good call
[Music]
damn he snagged one a good looking one
huh
i thought the show forgot about it yeah
now they heard you
they're like oh crap it's episode five
we gotta address that
oh
[Music]
m
oh you're gonna spark off a civil war
right now
[Music]
and she wrote all of that
yeah we can do it
[Laughter]
damn
this is a while developments what is the
name of that guy the master
uh um that would be oh dang it's uh on
young i think i'm gonna call him uh
master master
master
clearly
he knows something oh yeah that he's not
letting on
and i hope
crown prince's affinity towards him does
not cloud his judgment
because the way how like
um
muy young
stepped up to the plate and was like yo
we're sure about this guy he's like shut
the [ __ ] up
don't you ever speak that way again in
front of me about him you be careful man
i'll execute you myself making this
entanglements even more personal because
our prince would not be who he is today
if it wasn't for him you know clearly a
big part of his core memory
was like
you're gonna
be in a [ __ ] position
so you got to learn to look out for
yourself
you're already a bastard so this life is
going to be hard for you this is going
to be tough man yeah this is going to be
tough
i mean the first half hour was really
tense with the ship and then the
villagers and
yeah
like that whole sequence was just really
intense
that was that was uh
it was weird to have a sense of comfort
though is the first time the show did
that where it's like okay well if they
know what to do like aim for their heads
at least or like the neck up region
they'll be fine you got a few capable
warriors yeah so i don't like to be put
in that position too often though where
i'm like i feel safe yeah because i'm
like oh but it's more fun when we don't
know like when we're outgunned yeah
there's no way we can survive this yeah
grossly outnumbered yeah cause yeah that
was a terrifying sequence
and um
i thought the handling of that was great
because just the tension was so palpable
and you could tell these villagers were
we're not really out to help
oh yeah and i love that interplay too if
you get the double tension of them being
like hey out here in the middle of
nowhere no one will know we even killed
you and and and playing on that a lot
like they've done that a few times
over the past several episodes of people
being like i know the punishment is
severe and you're gonna kill me for this
yeah you know so it's always
highlighting like how
kind of ridiculous a lot of these
imperial consequences can be but yeah
like that initial tension of them being
like you're probably good at half of us
you know tortured or beheaded or
whatever and then you know you get the
outbreak and they don't understand
what's happening and then yeah that
totally sinister just like rising up
from beneath this the wheat or the straw
whatever their that field they're in is
and
two just like you know
classically to any zombie medium you
know or or anything that rides on like
oh the sun you know it's like the sun
starts to dip and you feel that tension
too of you see the moon and you're just
like no and even like this wide open
space feels threatening yeah man
so i'm kind of wondering though what
we're going to be doing about who's that
guy the cowardly guy
the magistrate or whatever yeah
magistrate cho i keep thinking he's
probably going to have some scene in the
next episode that shows his uh sense of
bravery he's got all the hearts all to
impress her right he just wants yeah he
wants to be so much that he's gonna grow
some just for her
but i've found him like it's weird like
as much of a cow like they've made him a
very endearing coward like it's it's
kind of funny up until that moment where
she's like dude
do something good for once
you know
there's some interesting history here to
explore so we've got the young shin
character
going to his
i want to see more of his backstory he's
really got that mysterious ass back
story
like what
why were you so good at what you do and
then there's a lot of alluding to and
ponderings but not really anything is
made clear-cut
about his background then they planted
these other seeds here like you got the
pregnant woman
uh and they because they established
that the queen she's
she had she missed carrie
was like that she was like bleeding yeah
i thought that was what that what that
meant so they're trying to like have
them you know like take one take one of
the babies they're gonna harvest just
the healthiest boy what if they take new
young wives baby
i'm so afraid that's what they're gonna
do then yeah
i mean
they're there yeah she's clearly the
healthiest and most well-kept among them
i mean you know they go ahead and
highlight the rest of them we're all
peasants they're like what are you doing
here perfect specimen lady
royal guard's wife
and yeah i i have to imagine that knife
twist is coming
the way they capture food here like how
visceral it is and the sound effects are
just like man they just
just made me want to eat
yeah all right i just want to get nasty
on it just
like hunger is such a big part of this
show and it's fascinating too because
you know it's like when you see it in
the zombie contest where that guy's
gnawing on the other dude's stomach it's
so gross and like it sounds good it
sounds good it sounds like a carl's jr
commercial
but then you see these these multiples
especially in this particular episode
it's multiple scenes of people just
chowing and it does
it it is enticing in a way you are like
yeah i want some give me some
weird thing that that guy did the
the show hawk guy um just like we fed it
to one guy
and it's like just put the guy alone in
the cage yeah
why did you need to create a mini spread
right here
what's the point of that or were you
just like ah we were gonna execute this
guy anyway
put him in the box
you know
so with the way that was ending with the
five armies was that demonstrating that
they are mainly going after the prince
or mainly trying to stop the containment
or is it all of the above
to that way they can just seize complete
power and perhaps let the epidemic take
care of these other people i think
that's what i would be inclined to
believe there's just nothing
about the show clan that seems like they
actually have a concern for stopping the
spread of this and even the way that
like they're watching
it's like you know they did they created
this problem trying to perpetuate the
king's life and now you know the guy
who's kind of pulling the strings
and han young now is like sitting there
just like observing all this and i'm
like you're taking notes or something
like you don't actually want to contain
this you probably have to
act that way but yeah i
the sense i got was that they're just
like isolating everyone so that they can
protect themselves yeah cutting
everybody else off from them
and then just letting the spread do what
it's gonna do i guess i guess it's gonna
turn into a fight for the throne because
it looks like there's a lot of people
who would believe in our crown prince
yeah and i mean they made a big deal out
of
if they get to anyone if i'm if i'm
remembering his name correctly like and
if he recognizes the crown prince's
legitimacy then that's a big trouble for
us and they do indeed link up this
episode
not that i am fully comfortable because
it seems like
at least anyone probably knows
uh or helped pioneer the experiments
with the resurrection plant that may
have led to the patient book like
there's got to be
some nugget maybe if it is the loss of
his his wife i think he's grieving for
all this time like maybe that had
something to do with it maybe they used
her to experiment i don't know but uh it
seems like at least the
from what we know already the seeds of
that clash and that you know fight to
instate you know li chang rightfully as
king you know is
is further along now for sure
[ __ ]
hey right this is a this is a really
gripping episode absolutely they've all
been great but uh this one in particular
had that was one of the most ten
sequences i think they've done
i just love the way that was staged
going through the crop field crop field
or hay field or yeah this crops i mean
it looked like wheat or hay or something
yeah i couldn't tell
with the crop field and then rising from
the ground poorly buried yeah
in stocks and stuff you can just really
feel the performers
really sorry for them like man you just
put them in there you guys cover them
yeah
you're already so sticky they're gonna
be like pulling petrified bits of plant
life off themselves feel like i get a
headache watching the behind the scenes
under the sun and then you get yeah all
those extras in the in the
heavy black guards
carrying these flags across the
countryside i'm like who are those even
let's see if you can see those you know
but uh i mean it's it's staggering
and it's fun you know because like cgi
often fills in blanks like that or or
helps to invest in if that's a word you
know like a crowd or whatever but like
it feels like they throw down on this
show for lots of extras to like
legitimize everything it feels huge
i mean the one qualm that i would have
with the show like it is the only qualm
is that because there's almost no cgi
that one that is cgi it really stands
out cg blood splats and stuff yeah or
the arrow yeah yeah yeah my god really
stands out just because there's almost
no cgi
[Music]
well that too that whole thing where
that guy takes the time to shoot the one
dude through the fence
was just like that okay you guys clearly
are on a human mission not a zombie
mission well anyone who opposes has to
be killed or even that's the rules for
questions yeah
his question what are you doing
kill him
that's treason
ugh communism
yeah that's fine or fatter or something
i don't know
fascism fascism maybe a blend of the
both maybe one in disguise with the
other
i just love it yeah what's the term guys
yeah like what is the structure here i
mean
i mean there is a certain amount of
i know a dictatorship is different from
a monarchy but i feel like in this
situation it is sort of like whatever
the king says
or the whatever the royal decree is so
it feels like a yeah like a dictatorship
but uh but yeah
just that juxtaposition i love that back
back that that
propel propulsion of
different types of hunger that that
thing that they explore throughout this
of like the ravenousness of people being
starved by
you know the political array of things
versus the voraciousness of just
these
hungry beings who won't stop yeah
good word voraciousness
all right guys well
that's the end of this episode i only
got one more to go
and then everything will be fine
we'll be back in power zombies
all right guys well keep a look out and
we'll catch you guys soon
[Music]
you